collègues dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Madame Françoise Gatel
auteur de la promotion de loi pour 10
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame leur rapporteur mes
chers collègues l'égalité de
représentation des femmes et des hommes
est un principe constitutionnel depuis
1999 ainsi pour les communes de plus de
1000 habitants le législateur a instauré
une règle de parité pour leur
représentation au conseil municipal mais
aussi au Conseil Communautaire
ces dispositions ont montré leur
efficacité puisque à l'issue du
renouvellement de 2020 le nombre de
femmes conseillères communautaire a
augmenté de plus de 4 points et atteint
désormais près de 39%. alors le sujet de
la parité dans l'intercommunalité son
amélioration
est souvent évoquée il convient
toutefois de rappeler que
l'intercommunalité n'est pas une
collectivité mais un établissement
public de coopération et que ces
conseill sont donc directement
issus des élections municipales puisque
les conseillers ils sont les
représentants de leur commune de ce fait
comme dans les syndicats la composition
de l'assemblée communautaire se doit de
respecter chaque élection municipale
cependant la règle de la parité prévoit
qu'en cas de vacances d'un siège de
conseiller communautaire au cours du
mandat le respect du principe de parité
continue à s'appliquer et le siège de
conseiller communautaire devenu vacances
doit être obligatoirement pourvu par un
élu communal du même sexe dans les
communes disposant de plusieurs sièges
au Conseil Communautaire cette règle de
parité peut donc aboutir à une vacance
durable du siège provoquant une
sous-représentation problématique et
contestable d'une commune au sein de son
EPCI
ces situations de sous-représentation
commence à émerger elles existent à
Reims au Havre à Fécamp mais aussi dans
des petites communes de la Nièvre ou de
Vendée comme un Talmont-Saint-Hilaire ce
problème est particulièrement aigu pour
les petites communes qui ne disposent
que de peu de conseillers communautaires
mais peut donc toucher aussi toutes les
communes de plus de 1000 et peut ainsi
aboutir à une grave diminution de leur
représentation au sein du conseil
communautaire la loi avait d'ailleurs
perçu dès le départ ces difficultés en
prévoyant une dérogation au principe de
remplacement par un élu du même sexe
pour les communes ne disposant que d'un
seul conseiller communautaire il
convient donc et c'est l'objet de cet
humble proposition de loi de corriger
cette rupture de l'égalité pour les
autres communes
c'est à dire celle de plus de 1000 car
pourquoi la moindre richement de la
représentation serait-il tolérée dans
certains cas et pas dans d'autres et je
voudrais ici rassurer mes collègues qui
pourraient craindre que ce projet de loi
ne soit une atteinte à la paille la
plupart des exemples que j'ai cités que
j'ai cité laisse penser que dans
beaucoup de cas c'est disposition risque
de bénéficier aux femmes car à ce jour
il y a je ne sais pas pourquoi je n'ai
pas fait de diagnostic plus des
démissions d'hommes que de femmes en
outre cette application
je laisse chacun apprécier en outre
cette application stricte du principe de
parité peut aboutir à ce que j'appelle
des accidents démocratiques fâcheux
comme à la moindrement des droites de
l'opposition celle-ci pouvant perdre
toute représentation conseil
communautaire quand elle n'a qu'un siège
alors même le pluralisme des courants
d'idées à acquis valeur
constitutionnelle donc je le disais tout
à l'heure si aujourd'hui ces situations
peuvent être encore peu nombreuses nul
ne peut
ignorer le risque de multiplication de
ce type de situation dans cette crise de
l'engagement je rappellerai
l'augmentation préoccupante des
démissions d'élus municipaux depuis 2020
le nombre de démission des mers depuis
2020 s'élèvent aujourd'hui mes chers
collègues à 930 et je ne connais pas à
ce stade le nombre de démission de
conseiller municipaux mais il y a là
gravité monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues permettez-moi de remercier
très chaleureusement notre rapporteur
Nadine belrot pour la très grande
qualité de son travail et son écoute et
n'oublions pas mes chers collègues que
l'intercommunalité nécessite encore
beaucoup d'apaisement et que
l'engagement comme la démocratie
sont aujourd'hui tous les deux d'une
grande fragilité avec humilité madame la
rapporteur monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre disons que ce petit pas
législatif qui vous est proposé
aujourd'hui peut-être considéré comme un
grand pas pour la démocratie je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole